you ever done this if you've had an
argument with someone that you really
care about
about something you couldn't give a [ __ ]
about
i had an argument with a friend of mine
that i've known for 15 years about
whether tomatoes are a fruit or a
vegetable
who cares also it got me thinking can't
something be both a fruit
and a vegetable i mean what if graham
norton had a serious accident
[Music]
and in entertainment news ellen
degeneres and lover ann hesh
have announced that they want to have a
baby however their plan has hit a snag
they are both women
[Applause]
it is not possible
to i don't know about you but i don't
like celebrities that are only famous
because of who their parents are
like callum best and peaches geldof and
jesus
did you have uh uh alec baldwin
oh yeah every season pretty much he's
amazing i don't know what he's doing now
he was unreal weird tweets
but he used to come when he was i was a
lot younger i guess because it was when
i started which was 20 years ago and uh
he had he was married to kim basinger
and he complained about her like you
know the most beautiful woman
yeah [ __ ] wife she bought a town
she was mad because she bought a town a
town she bought a whole town
[Laughter]
so their credit score went down
so you bought a town and then he comes
in baldwin looks perfect you know
he just had dinner with lauren and he
goes he's trying to be like us you know
one of the guys
he goes that uh that secretary no not
that he didn't say secretary
he goes that assistant girl out there
man i saw my left leg i have to [ __ ] her
jesus christ and i said i think all you
have to do is ask her
if you're alex i think you're all right
does he think that difference
because the music is phenomenal outside
of that okay it's real simple yeah have
you ever been locked up at a mental
institute
no he has yeah they don't just lock you
up bro they never locked me up
yeah you know my wife never i never came
home my wife has some [ __ ]
two gorillas that are in uh those uh lab
suits
that are staring at me i'm like what's
with the big guys oh these big guys are
gonna take you to a nice hospital
like sir we'd like to handle this
quietly what yeah yeah the [ __ ] i'm not
going to some hospital
you know i can't stop you
you don't just go to the mental
institute bro they [ __ ]
they velcro you but the mental intuition
doesn't mean that you're
genius there's a lot of crazy people who
are just crazy yeah
yeah well he's definitely crazy sure but
he's also
but he's brilliant too see the work that
comes out of that crazy
is genius work right so what is it about
him
that allows him to be so prolific as an
artist do you ever notice how prolific
he is
yes the guy's constantly music
constantly banging out songs
con he doesn't have bad albums no
he's he is phenomenal at music without a
doubt phenomenal at music but
this is all from this energy that's
inside of him he figures out how to
channel that energy
and put it in good ways but occasionally
like it's not all it's just
not a coincidence it's not a coincidence
that when
kanye was on stage i think it was in san
jose yeah and he said
that he didn't vote but if he was going
to vote he would have voted for trump
and the crowd went crazy and they booed
the [ __ ] out of him and then he
cancelled his tour and then he went to
the
mental health institute right all that
[ __ ] happened together because
he felt the pain of this then his
response to that was to double down
his response to that was to attribute
qualities to trump that he doesn't even
really have
right and so trump in his
so in a lot of ways very wise the way he
handles things socially
he let kanye come into the white house
yeah where that maga hat and just rant
up a storm
yeah so kanye could define who trump was
he could define what loving trump meant
sure he could define why black people
should
it should embrace trump he could define
all this in his head to sort of justify
what went wrong with him right and then
trump just sits there and goes like this
and lets him talk
and then he leaves and trump goes what
the [ __ ] are you familiar with simon
cowell do you know simon cowell
simon cowell spends 500 000 pounds
every year on his own personal security
that's an extraordinary amount of money
isn't it
half a million pounds a year on personal
security assignment not considered
being less of a [ __ ]
oprah winfrey's longtime boyfriend
steadman graham
has written a new book called you can
make it happen
a nine step plan for success step number
one
become oprah winfrey's boyfriend
[Music]
and the other ada just hang around
she's gonna be uh you know on that show
and naomi campbell she's like 52 and she
still looks sexy so it's like
tyra got a lot of years to go jake yeah
who did we see walking away from that
hotel that day
oh cheryl t sheryl teague still looking
good that time is a [ __ ] man
are you really good time is a [ __ ] no
i'm not a realist
judgmental [ __ ] but i think you
got a bit of a fetish i've known you for
a while
and older white women and he picked some
bad one hillary clinton
my favorite white woman number one is uh
carly simon i will still pop boy simon i
don't know why i don't know why
everybody got their [ __ ] fetishes
cover alone well she was on all fours oh
wow that big mouth yeah that's what i'm
saying [ __ ] kill
lebron man that [ __ ] by the way a lot
of people backed us up on that one
oh yeah back yeah a lot of people were
calling in the same boat
moving back though we saw cheryl teagues
leaving uh the donald trump roast yeah
cheryl t because we have the great seats
from voss
well yeah barely in the building thanks
richard
i got your tickets for the trump road
section oh it's gonna be great
you know where we were the ushers from
the upper we were behind
a monitor that was showing the roast
behind it on the second floor dude
everyone's going in the main ballroom
and we
handed our tickets like oh we're gonna
be hobnobbing with the
the top celebrities in new york right
also the usher looks at our tickets and
goes
oh you got to take that elevator
but and then you're thinking all right
well you know it's an elevator
you ever see a roast where there's an
upstairs it's always
it's the the deus and the table right so
we're like upstairs that are roasted so
at first we're like all right well we'll
follow all the other people that have
seats in that area no there were maybe
another
20 people that had seen in that area and
we sit down and then i i i
my seat stunk i i don't stand up and
look over this video screen to see
anything
i couldn't tell who was up at the the
they were tired
everybody getting the elevators like
holding cable and [ __ ]
yeah that's what it was they were all
tech guys gaffers
they were heading for the [ __ ] mixing
board
so we're heading for the walkways high
above so we leave the roast we're
walking back
toward the station and uh we're right
behind cheryl teagues and her
white old saggy ass
like how bad did it look
here's what i'm saying for an old old
lady
she probably isn't that bad but when you
compare her to the cheryl teagues poster
that was on everybody's wall
with the netting that she was just
wearing a net and her nipples were
poking through i mean you wouldn't [ __ ]
sophia lauren
no just because she exists 60 something
years old
you gotta pop a dude
there's got to be a just a glimpse of
just young
sophia's one drug yeah half a [ __ ] lip
ain't
nothing believe me and when you see
these people
out remember they are looking their
absolute best all right this is the best
they can possibly look
how old are sherry teagues 50 gotta be
she's gotta be
inner inner fifty five and it should not
be there's
no redeeming sexuality i didn't see any
redeeming sexuality i saw
an older woman that you look at and go
all right she's you know an older woman
that doesn't look like she's ready to
fall apart
okay what do you you know the old
brothers yeah
women like who continue to dye their
hair like that long it becomes like a
[ __ ] bird's nest it's all
dried out and then also like hershey's
you get into like you get into like your
60s it's like
the smell of rotten of your impending
death so you start having that old
person's smell so and you see the top of
the head yeah
when it gets to what you talk you see
right through that cotton candy hair
it's like a [ __ ] white cotton candy
hair and you see scalp right
now that rain is a little dangerous in
the back of her hand and she's jerking
you off
you gotta you got a [ __ ] old sofia
lorraine [ __ ] movie on the tv
trying not to look at the what happened
to that wait wait cheryl
don't check out that cup that's not the
coke jesus had no that's the wrong
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] close your eyes sofia
close your eyes don't look at him